قالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان وزيرها اكد في
اللقاء الذي جمعه بالسفير الامريكي لدى
بيجين على ضروره ان توقف الولايات الامم
المتحده ما سماه الاضرار بسياره الصين
مشددا على استقرار العلاقات بين البلدين
وتجنب وقوع حوادث بينهما السفير الامريكي
من جانبه اكد على ان بلاده لا تريد حربا
بارده مع الصين بل ترغب في قنوات تواصل
دائمه معها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم سياق
توقيت القائد الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
الصيني بعد فتره توتر على خلفيه سياسه
واشنطن تجاه تايوان وما الملفات التي دفعت
باتجاه حصوله وما دلاله التزامن بين هذا
اللقاء وبين اعلان الصين عملها على تسهيل
التفاوض الروسي الامريكي بشان الحربي
الروسيه الاوكراني بشان الحربي في
اوكرانيا وكيف سينعكس ذلك على التواصل بين
البلدين
وما التحديات التي تمنع تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين بالنظر لتعقيلات العلاقه على
المستويين الاقتصادي والامني
[موسيقى]
التازم في العلاقات بين الصين وامريكا لم
يمنع اللقاء بين وزير الخارجيه الصيني
والسفير الامريكي لدى بيجين للحديث عما
يمكن ان يخفف التوتر بين الجانبين في
الاجنده ملفات الخلافيه جرى طرحها وسط
اجواء الدوليه تسيطر عليها الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكذلك تصاعد ازمه مضيق تايوان
وزير الخارجيه الصيني قال ان استقرار
العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه امر ضروري
وحيوي لكنه شدر في المقابل على ان على
واشنطن احترام الخط الاحمر لبيجين في
اشاره لقضايا تعتبرها الصين من جوهر امنها
القومي تتقدمها تايوان
السفير الامريكيه لدى بيجين نيكولاس بانس
وبعد ان اشار الى واقع المنافسه بين
البلدين قال ان واشنطن لم تغير سياسه
الصين الواحده منذ خمسين عاما مشيرا في
الان نفسه الى ان بلاده تحاول تحسين
العلاقه
وتعميق قنوات الاتصال مع بيجين وذلك
بتوسيعها وجعلها بين مستويات ارفع في
اداره البلدين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور
السابق للتعاون والانخراط الدوريه لحل
الازمات في البيت الابيض خلال اداره
الرئيس الامريكيه الاسبق باراك اوباما
وسيكون معنا ضيوف اخرون في ثنايا هذه
الحلقه هذا اللقاء الذي حدث في بيجيل بين
وزير الخارجيه الصيني
والسفير الامريكي هو اول لقاء يجريه وزير
الخارجيه الصيني مع اي مسؤول امريكي منذ
واقعه البالونات هل نفهم او نعرف
الملابسات التي عقد فيها هذا اللقاء هل هو
بطلب امريكي هل هو بطلب صيني من الذي سعى
لعقد هذا اللقاء
اعتقد ان هنالك عده ملاحظات باستطاعتنا ان
نستخلصها حتى لو ان تفاصيل اللقاء لم يتم
الاعلان عنها بشكل كبير وبعضها قد لم يتم
الكشف عنها لكن بدايه فان هذا
اللقاء كان من جهد صيني محاوله تخفيف
التوتر بعد كانت هنالك زياده للتوتر بشكل
كبير خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه كان
هنالك الردود العدائيه من بيجين نتجاه
زياره
رئيسه
لتايوان ومؤخرا كان هنالك الرد المؤثر
لزياره الرئيس الرئيس التوانيه للولايات
المتحده هذا بالتاكيد اضاف الى التوتر
وايضا كان هنالك منصاد التجسس التجسس عفوا
كانت قضيه
صعبه
واستدعت رده من الصين موقف من اوكرانيا
بالتالي كل هذه الامور كانت امور خلافيه
واعتقد انه بسبب الضغط السياسي والاقتصادي
الذي تشعر به الصين وايضا من الخارج هي
تسعه لتخفيف التوتر
لفتح طريق نحو الامام بالتالي اعتقد انها
مدت بغصن الزيتون الى واشنطن وتسعه لاعاده
المحادثات وما
ارادته من واشنطن تاكيد على وجود مناطق
قلق مشتركه واعتقد ان هذا الامر هو كان
الطاغي على الاحاديث بالتاكيد نحن نتعاون
في قضايا اخرى منها التغيرات المناخيه
مثلا يعني هذا اللقاء ياتي بعد اسبوع من
تصريحات للسفير الامريكي في بيجين
نيكولاسبونز عن السداد واشنطن
للحوار في اي لحظه مع الصين وياتي ايضا
بعد اسبوع من تصريح الوزير بلانكن وزير
الخارجيه من ان زيارته التي ارججت بسبب
البالون الصيني
اورجا قد يعاد جدولتها وياتي ايضا بعد
اسبوع من تصريح جون كريم مسؤول المناخ في
الاداره الامريكيه انه قد يعقد لقاء قريبا
جدا مع الجانب الصيني هل هل مساله البالون
تم تجاوزها
اعتقد بالتاكيد هنا في الولايات المتحده
هي لا تضغط على الوسائل الاعلام مثلا او
حتى في الاحاديث التي تجري في اروقه
السياسه اقول ذلك لكن اعتقد ان هنالك
الكثير من القضايا التي لم يتم ايجاد حلها
وبالتاكيد فان الوزير
سيخبر نظيره الصيني ان هذا الامر لا يمكن
ان يستمر لا يمكن للصينيين ان يستمروا الى
الولايات المتحده وعلينا ان لا ننسى انه
كان هنالك بالونات في اماكن مختلفه في
العالم علينا ان تعتبر هذه البناطيل خرقا
للقانون الدولي ولن يتم تحمل هذا الامر
هنالك مشكله كبيره ولا يجب ان يتم تكرار
هذا الحدث واعتقد ان بيجين بالتاكيد ستعطي
ضمانات من ان هذه النشاطات لن تستمر
الجزء الاخر والذي هو بغايه الاهميه ايضا
ان وزير الخارجيه الصيني سيسافر الى
اوروبا بالتالي اعتقد ان الاجتماع مع
السفير الامريكي في بيجين كان ايضا لفتح
المجال للدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه لاظهار انه
واشنطن وبيجين ليس على مسافات متباعده
بالتالي هذا الامر سيفتح مجالا امام بيجين
لوزير
الخارجيه في فرنسا والنرويج وفي المانيا
لربما ان يكون له
فرصه لاجراء تطور في تطوير في العلاقات
وللاستمرار في النقاشات والحديث وبما انك
ذكرت
الجوله التي سيقوم بها وزير الخارجيه او
قام بدا بالفعل وزير الخارجيه الصيني الى
اوروبا
هل الولايات المتحده ينبغي ان تقلق من هذه
الزياره لاسيما مع تصريحات سابقه لدوله
مهمه كفرنسا عبر رئيسها مانويل ماكرو بان
النزاع في تايوان لا ناقه لنا فيه ولا جمل
هل الانفتاح الصيني على اوروبا مقلق
للولايات المتحده
هذا الامر كان مصدر قلق دائما في واشنطن
وكان الحال في فتره الرئيس اوباما
الاوروبيون لا يدركون التهديد الذي تمثله
الصين في قضايا مثل التكنولوجيا وايضا
مثلا
التكنولوجيا الانترنت لكن عندما يتعلق
الامر ايضا
بالطموحات الجيو السياسيه للصين اذا ما
رايناه من رحله الرئيس ماكرون في الصين
كان شرحا لهذا الامر الرئيس الفرنسي كان
ينظر الى الحصول على مكاسب اقتصاديه وكان
مستعدا لكي يغض النظر عن بعض القضايا
الاساسيه السياسيه التي ترغب الولايات
المتحده من فرنسا ومن بقيه اوروبا ان
تعترف بها وتميزها وبالتالي هذا الامر
قد يسمح للاطراف الاوروبيه من انخراط برج
الجانب الاقتصادي على امل ان يمنح لهم بعض
منافع السياسيه للصين مع الولايات المتحده
ومع دول اوروبيه اخرى في هذا اللقاء وهو
اللقاء الاول وزير الخارجيه الصيني امريكي
منذ حادث البالون كما ذكرنا في هذا اللقاء
الذي خرج من تصريحات الجانبين بيان وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه وايضا تغريدات تغريده
واحده في الواقع للسفير الامريكي
الطرفان تحدثاه عن ضروره استقرار العلاقه
وايضا
مقابله كل طرف الطرف الاخر في منتصف
الطريق ما هو منتصف الطريق
اعتقد ان منتصف الطريق الى الطرفان انهم
توافقا على عده امور وعلى انهم سيختلفوا
عنها لكنهم سيحاولوا ان يبقوا هذه
الخلافات في توافقات ربما واسعه بامكانهم
يسمحوا لها ان تعرقل نمو العلاقه علينا
هنالك بعض المجالات ذات المصالح المشتركه
مثلا الاقتصاديه التغيرات المناخيه حتى في
مساله التعاون الامني ومواجهه التحديات
مثل كوريا الشماليه
وانتشار النووي بالتالي فان واشنطن تريد
ان تركز على هذه الامور ان باستطاعتنا ان
نتعاون في عده مجالات دعونا نضع جانبا بعض
الخلافات حول القضايا التي قد نتوافق
عليها ام لا ونامل انه سيكون هنالك
اجراءات لبناء الثقه خلال الاشهر القادمه
التي ستسمح للامور ان تعود بالع
مثلا في الخلاف الصيني الامريكي على
تايوان
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
حول العلاقات صينيه امريكيه وكذلك مساله
تتعامل مع العلاقاتها مع الولايات المتحده
على اساس الاحترام لمتبادل وتعاير سلمي
والتعاون وفوز المشترك
وهذا ولكن اكدت يعني كذلك لا يمكن
للولايات المتحده ان تبحث
مع الصين قنوات الحوار والتواصل في في من
ناحيه وفي نفس الوقت يعني تعمل
تقوم
بالتحركات لاحتواء الصين فيك جميل مجالات
اولا اكدت سن يعني على الجانبين
يعني تطوير علاقات وبحث سبل التعاون
والحوار على اساس الاحترام لمتبادل
والمساواه وهذا هو شروط يعني شروط مسبقه
الاستئناف الحوار يعني تدوير العلاقات على
الولايات المتحده ذلك الله تصحيح السلوكها
الخاطئه يعني خلال الفتره الاخيره وكذلك
يعني لا تعتبر السين او تتعامل مع الصين
بفكره
اللعبه الصفريه او فكره الحرب البارده
وكذلك
على الولايات على
المثاليه يتم تراك ان العالم
يستطيع استيعاب التطور معا للولايات
المتحده والصين وفوز المتحده لا يجب ان
يكون على اساس التربه ضربات على الصين
وكذلك يعني فشل للصين لذلك هذا هو ما يريد
ان
تفهم هذا هو الموقف التحصيلي الحالي يعني
هذه هي التصريحات لكن الاشاره التي جاءت
الى منتصف الطريق كنت اريد ان افهم منك
بالنسبه للتيوان هل هنالك منتصف طريق
بالنسبه للصين هل هنالك حل وسط ما بين
الموقف الامريكي وما بين الموقف الصيني ام
ان الحلول الوسط التي قصدها البيان الصيني
لا تتعلق بتايوان وانما تتعلق بقضايا اخرى
كالمناخ على سبيل المثال
اعتقد بالنسبه الى مساله ليس هناك اي
تنازل رئيسي في هذا في هذه المساله
فقط اريد ان اعرف هذا الموقف شكرا لكم
ارجو ان تبقى معنا ايضا هنالك تصريح لافت
لمستشار الامن القومي الامريكيه الاسبق
هنري علق على تطورات العلاقات بين
الولايات المتحده والصين قائلا ان دخول
الصين على خط النزاع الروسيه الاوكراني قد
يقود الى محادثات سلام اضاف كسنجر بعد
بلوغه المئه عام ان الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه دخلت نقطه تحول واتوقع محادثات
في نهايه العام بسبب الجهود الصينيه
الاخيره
طبعا هو الذي بدا العلاقه مع الصين في عهد
واريد ان اسال ضيفنا من بيجين من نواشنطون
الدكتور
هو الذي رتب لزياره نيكسون للصين
فيما يتعلق بملف اوكرانيا واحتمال ان تقوم
الصين فعلا بجهود وساطه وان تحرس تقدما
كبيرا في انهاء هذه الحرب الولايات
المتحده بهذا اللقاء هي تمهد
لهذا الدور الصيني ام توضح موقف امريكا من
اي دور صيني في هذه المحادثات
ساقول ان الصين حاليا لديها نفوذ اكبر على
موسكو او مقارنه بواشنطن او باي دوله اخرى
بالتالي الرئيس الصيني وساقول باستطاعته
هو يجب ان يستخدم هذا النفوذ لكي يضغط على
الرئيس بوتين ويقول له ان هذه الحرب يجب
ان تنتهي لكن هنالك مشكله اخرى
الرئيس الصيني ان فلاديمير بوتين كان كان
قد اجبر من
على ان مساله
ان مساله قوانين او الاعراف الدوليه يجب
ان تؤكد انه لا يجب ان تقوم دوله اخرى
غصبا باخذ اراضي دوله اخرى بالتالي فان
التايوان ربما تواجه اوقاتا صعبه بعدما
قام به بوتين في اوكرانيا لان المجتمع
الدولي
لاننا سؤالي الى اي مدى تعول الولايات
المتحده عذرا ساعيد هذا السؤال الى اي مدى
تعولت المتحده على دور صيني في انهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهل تريد فعلا الولايات
المتحده دورا صينيا لانهاء هذه الحرب
مره اخرى اعتقد ان الثقه قد لا تكن مئه
بالمئه لكن اذا ما لعبت الصين في اضافه
الضغط على موسكو فان الامر سيكون من
مصلحته الصين ان تنتهي هذه الحرب وان تكون
قادره على ان يكون هنالك تبادل للبضائع
والخدمات بشكل مفتوح مع
روسيا ومع اوكرانيا عندما يتعلق الامر
بمساله عدم الاستقرار الغذاء بالتاكيد فان
الصين تسعه وتنظر الى اوكرانيا وتزعل
الحصول على القمح والحوض الاوكرانيه اصيل
لديها دور لكي تلعبها السؤال هو اذا ما هي
الشروط لا اعتقد ان اوكرانيا والرئي
سيقبلوا فكره ان هنالك جزء كبير من ارضه
سيتم ضمه الى موسكو بالقوه هذا هو التحدي
امام الرئيس اذا ما دخل باي محاوله لانهاء
صراع او للمفاوضات بين الطرفين واليه مدى
الصين مستعده لان تقوم بهذا الدور السيد
روان من بيجين الى اي مدى الصين مستعده
للقيام بهذا الدور وفي مقابل ماذا يعني
اذا حققته ما الذي سيعود على الصين من
تحقيق هذا الدور سوى ان يقال ان الصين صنع
سلام انظروا لقد صنعت السلام بين السعوديه
وايران وهي الان تصنع السلام بين روسيا
واوكرانيا هل هنالك اكثر من ذلك
طبعا الصين مستعده
يعني اللاعب دور بناءه
لاحلال السلام في اوكرانيا في اي وقت
فالسين منذ بدايه هذه الازمه يعني تدعو
الى
يعني
وايجاد حل سياسي من خلال التفاوض والحوار
فهذا لان هذا يتفق مع مصالح معظم دول
والشعوب في المنطقه وكذلك يعني الاستقرار
والسلام في القاره الاوروبيه كذلك يسب
لصالح حسين لذلك
السين ستبتل اكثر جهودها لانجاح ذلك لان
كما قلت السلام والاستقرار يسب لصالح
لمعظم الدول في الاعلى لكن هل هذه ورقه
تفاوض ربما تكون
سواء في لقاء اليوم بين السفير الامريكي
ووزير الخارجيه الصيني او في لقاءات مقبله
انحدثت بين اي مسؤول من الجانبين اذا كان
ما حدث اليوم هو مقدمه لمحادثات في
المستقبل المساله الصين مساله اوكرانيا هي
ورقه التفاوض سنقوم بهذا الدور في مقابل
كذا وكذا في مضيق تايوان مثلا ام لا
اعتقد الوساطه الصينيه في هذه في الازمات
في العلامات قضايا الدوليه
ليس من الضروره اون لا ترتبط باي شروط
مسبقه يعني لكي يكون هذا مقابل لشيء ما
وهذا يعني هذا الشكل
كان هدفها وكذلك هدف لمساعده في
السعوديه والايران هو وكلها من اجل الدفاع
السلام والاستقرار في العالم لان هذا يسب
لصالح معظم الدول في العالم هل تعتقد ذلك
ايضا السيد بريت سبراون ان دور الصيني
للوساطه في مساله اوكرانيا لا يكون مرتبطا
بما يجري في مضيق تايوان لن يكون محل
تفاوض مع الولايات المتحده اذا حدث لقاءات
في المستقبل
اعتقد انه لا يمكننا ان نبعد قضيه تايوان
ببساطه لان الصين قد جعلت من هذا الامر
جزءا اساسيا من سياستها الخارجيه ومن
الواضح من جهودها واجراءاتها خلال السنه
الماضيه في انخراطها بطريقه عدائيه
وعسكريه
وخلق
تايوان بشكل كامل بالتالي قامت هذا هذه
الصين بهذه الاجراءات المؤسفه وجعلت من
هذا الامر ملمحا اساسيا من سياستها
الخارجيه اعتقد ان على الصين ان توضح بشكل
كامل بسياستها المستقبليه وعليها ان تطمئن
العالم انها لن تسيطر على تايوان بالقوه
واعتقد ان هنالك حلول وسط كما ذكر من
بيجين فان الصين تحاول ان تبني سمعتها على
انها دوله مستقر
مصانع سلام في الشرق الاوسط وفي اوروبا
لكن اذا ما ارادت القيام بذلك عليها ان
تظهر وتكون مستعده لعقد السلام مع تايوان
ايضا الدكتور
السابق للتعاون والانخراط الدولي لحالي
الازمات في البيت الابيض خلال اداره
الرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما نشكرك ضيفنا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
[موسيقى]